Shannon's a strong kid and a tough
fighter
that's Jason priestly praising his
former Beverly Hills 90210 co-star
shannen doherty as she bravely fights
breast cancer
Jason spoke with et on Wednesday at the
raising the bar to end Parkinson's gala
in LA at restaurant Laurel point where
he offered his support for the
forty-five year old actress I haven't
talked to Shannon but you know obviously
I follow her on social media and you
know what she did the other day was
shaving her head and put his posting the
pictures and everything there you know
that way that was incredibly brave and I
know that she's going to come through
this fight and she's going to be okay
you know she's she's always been uh
she's always been a tough kid she's
utilizing this to really try to shine a
light and to help other people and I got
nothing but love for her and I know that
she's gonna come out of this okay
Tiffani Thiessen also starred on the
iconic teen drama she too extended her
well wishes of course I totally heard
the news I just I never worked with
Shannon so I really don't have a
relationship with her but I wish her all
the best of course
you